hey what's up everyone i am your host
megan cameron and welcome to today's
marvel a let's play as you can tell by
the title of this stream we are going to
be playing marvel's spider-man miles
morales which is just such a great game
in itself but i don't know if you guys
have heard there was a new suit drop
that happened yesterday
oh
and it is a real beauty with a capital
b
beauty
it is the advanced tech suit maybe you
guys have already seen it i've already
tested it out i kind of want to take a
closer look
head into photo mode
i don't know
you know edit it up real nice maybe for
instagram maybe for the fridge
maybe maybe it's about time i start my
marvel uh scrapbook
specific to spider-man i mean
maybe maybe now is the time i don't know
i don't know let's see let's let's let's
dig into the gameplay rick and the
evidence might be on finn's phone oh
yeah a slab by the way
look at how beautiful it is here let me
let me do something cool it's kind of
the weather isn't
people in chat does anyone does it look
outside right now does it look like this
does it look like this is where you're
living right now in uh los angeles it's
it's a little bit sunny i'm not gonna
lie
oh my goodness i'm pressing all the
that did buttons work out
hang on i was trying to do something
cool
during the holidays um everyone in chat
have you had a chance to check out this
suit if so
what do you think
just like that
oh i keep doing the wrong way oh my
goodness let's get it together megan
anyway
i'm zooming don't mind me i got
something i'm working on great time to
donate to your local shelters
until next time remember to check your
credit score annually get one free
report free i'm trying oh that's what
i'm doing gotcha
hang on let's go into the
the menu screen real quick to show you
guys the suit
also i don't know about you guys when
you play the game do you do this with
your body
as you're just kind of like zooming
through
i
i i try and be real cool and not do that
but if you see me like kind of hovering
and going from left to right and side to
side
um
just like
just ignore it all right just let me be
just just just let it happen so here is
the suit
in all of its glory
gaming alicia puppy lover says it's
storming over here oh so then you can
you can kind of relate any snow
gosh look at this suit how tight is this
suit it's so beautiful
all of the layers
i think one of my favorite things about
just like
the marvel universe is just seeing
people
cosplay um and whenever a new
suit is released
or a new costume is announced it's so
exciting to think of the possibilities
of
of like
seeing this at an event or something
it looks so good seriously
this looks incredible
okay let's let's do something cool and
head into photo mode
i think i
i'm not very sure what it is i'm
actually
i'm actually doing
there we go
there it is
we kept hitting smashing the wrong
button okay i don't know if you guys
have tested this out yet i was messing
around with it the other day
and it is really fun you can mess with
the uh
the point of view let's do selfie let's
do the selfie camera type
um we're using the advanced tech suit
let's add a little bit of tilt here
also if you guys were miles
what kind of photos would you be taking
of yourselves would you would it would
you stick to the selfie or would you
kind of like set the camera up in like
you know in like a corner and then like
do the the timer and then swing by and
just look like it's you know paparazzi
type of a photo i i just feel like i
would always be i'd always be doing this
selfie maybe like throw the phone
in the air and then like
hit the capture button with like
with your web that would be tight i mean
that looked pretty cool
let's see we can mess with the exposure
the fov
aperture
making things a little bit blurrier in
the background
she's kind of brie i love the photo mode
in this game it's pretty cool right
it's so advanced they have uh filters
too
oh
vapor
i don't know are you guys partial to to
filters
you guys like it do you like it original
you like just like the clean vanilla are
you like just take the picture and post
it
or do you always have to have a filter
you know i i'd be lying if i was just
like oh just you know capture it in the
moment
since i uh i am you know a bit of an
influencer i do the edit
and then i gotta find the right filter
that just really
says it all
i'm not for sure i think i don't i don't
know if i like any of these filters for
this one specifically
oh
going through all of this is so
ridiculous
you can add stickers to it too i'm just
going through all of them just because
there's so many good ones that you guys
i've got to see
it's also neat taking a closer look at
the suit to be honest oh
spiderman yes
love it
love a good kitty cat
oh man that's great that would be this
would be really good for the scrapbook
if i could be honest
ah that's kind of cool
all right
you know since i'm here working on this
um why don't you guys go ahead and
uh take pictures of the new suit in
photo mode and make sure you tag us tag
me at strawberry17 and at marvel games
on social i would love to see
what you guys do there's just there's
really there's just so many options i
feel like you guys can get really
creative with this one
there is wait
there's something that you can do that
that is kind of crazy hang on one sec
light mode there we go
whoa look at that
isn't that cool that looks super crazy
we can change the color too
um
when you can do the cast shadows on or
off that looks insane
you know when you're like a little kid
and you like
there's like like a light and like on
the floor like whether it's like your
like your friend's garden or maybe
outside in your front yard and you go
over it and you get the like the spooky
shadows this is it
this is that right now this is the
moment
oh the red looks so cool but i don't
know
pink is like my favorite color so can
you guys tell what's everyone's favorite
color
everyone say pink ready one two three
it's pink i know
you don't have to tell me i just guessed
it i already guess your favorite color
i'm i could honestly spend so long just
doing this the red did look really cool
though
rj nim i don't think spidey needs a
filter he already looks so good
you know what
you're right you kind of can't mess with
perfection right if it's good it's good
so
everyone in chat right now
uh how many of you guys have already
played through uh spider-man's
miles morales you guys beat the game you
already coasted through
i'm gonna be honest
for you guys specifically
i decided not to uh
spoil any of this or jump too far ahead
i wanted to
i wanted to play it fresh so that you
guys can get
my uh
my live reactions as i go through and
play the game so right now we're
basically on chapter 10
corporate espionage
um is uh the chapter
a little bit of background
uh miles poor miles he's just
discovering a lot there's there's just
so much happening to him this game
um he just discovered that his childhood
friend finn
is the tinker which is like it's not
good they just got in like a fight
it was pretty
i'm just saying it's not like it's not
the way you want to like hang out with
your friends you know you want to play
video games with your friends you want
to you want to catch up maybe eat some
pizza have a good time you definitely
don't want to like hang out with your
friends and then you know find out that
they're possibly a bad guy and
you know they just punched you in the
face like that's never that's never too
great
so miles was having a very interesting
day his mom just got like i think she
broke her arm
the good news is she has a cast and
we're gonna be able to sign it roxanne
research labs
this is where the whole new form project
got started
ooh finn's phones in there chica you
platinumed it nice
darks are daring like 10 times you want
to do it again
just such a good story i love miles
i love the spider-verse
i just i just love it all
right that finn has high voltage
shooting
i wonder what power is it
i love all of miles
powers too oops
scan for this i'm going to disable it
somehow
okay okay okay
oh this is a bad guy i
i messed up everyone i messed up i
wasn't paying attention i was talking to
you guys we were talking about favorite
colors and i just i did it bad
oh my god
this is not good
guys what's your approach on this you
know when it's like be sneaky
i never do that i never listen
i'm always just like
like i i go in there and i i smash and
crash that's just like my thing oh man
gotta get out of there
this is not good
hang on one sec let me heal up
whoo
um everyone i just want to apologize in
advance for just the way that uh i i
just started this um
let me just make it right okay i'm just
just let me take care of this guy real
quick
we're almost we're almost done here
oh sweet i just kicked
kicked okay everyone's taken care of
we're all good
um
i am the least sneakiest miles morales
i
i think i'm like i'm definitely chaotic
that's my play style if it's your first
time watching me uh play video games uh
it's just it's never gonna be a dull
moment that's that's one thing you can
definitely look forward to
i wonder if i can power things down
we're good
i'm good
and i'm in it um i'm on my second cup of
coffee for the day
oh
all right
hold l2
and l1
oh oh
okay
hey
look look at that
technology
just kidding
okay
so i just do a lap full of arm guards
christmas break sure is prediction
prediction time should be at home
taking naps
playing a ton of video games oh taking
naps and videos christmas cookies i love
that press one in chat if you think
i'm gonna approach this next guard
situation very stealthily
press two
if you think it's just gonna be a repeat
of what just happened you're not gonna
hurt my feelings
if i just like i wanna see if i could uh
i could prove myself wrong that's this
honestly that's the that's the
motivation i need right now
broadway empire what's up
how are you today megan i'm doing pretty
good i just made a fool of myself you
know by just you know
um smashing a bunch of buttons but it's
it's totally cool i'm good
gavin kelly do you have a favorite suit
oh there's a lot of suits that oh this
they're offline there's a lot of really
great suits to be honest and i haven't
even locked all of them
um
the handmaid's like the homemade suit
i i guess that's just like that's that's
something that always will just feel a
little bit special it's kind of cool
tracksuit is really cool
i would like a whole outfit that just
looks like this to be honest just so i
can like hang out in it and live my best
life
but uh the advanced tech suit is really
cool what about everyone else in chat do
you have a favorite a favorite suit
the bodega suit's pretty tight too
jen messed up it's more fun to just run
into the action thank you
i
i feel seen
to be honest that was like uh
thank you for that seriously
let's go this way
megan not only is a stealth master she's
the best balance ever
okay well that is definitely a lie
i uh
yep nope all right this is not the way
to go
let's sort this out
wait
i just go in a circle huh the guy who
installed that is clearly padding his
resume
whoa
okay i went in a circle on purpose
it's one of my favorite shapes
so
it was intentional
you ever mess up and then like really
try and play it off as like something
you did on purpose
and you almost like as you're explaining
it you kind of convince yourself that
you definitely did do it on purpose
oh whoa this looks crazy
anyways that tangent is the story of my
life
oh oh oh
whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
whoa whoa
this is looking
this is looking real sketchy i'm not
gonna lie
okay guys i'm a little spooked
i'm a little spooked right now
um
tracker said the phone was pretty far
below ground level
all right
let's uh let's
why i feel scared i feel like something
scary is about to happen i it's not
right i just need to calm down this is
my first time playing this this chapter
right i'm okay
i don't know it's quiet
i jump scare easily
i've already embarrassed myself once
if it's underground kill them spiderman
or tinkerer detain them understood sir
we need backup
okay let's take care of this guy
oh my god
okay they're gone
wait this is
there was no way i was gonna take out
all of them right
i did the right thing only one
what's so funny
damn miles we're a skinny ass kid
you hit hard uncle aaron
you're the prowler the first time he's
figuring this out
i know
and i bet you got a lot of questions
right now oh my gosh we need to get out
of here
you picked the wrong place to break into
uh-oh i'm not leaving till i find what i
came for
listen
i did some work for roxanne a while back
you don't want to mess with these guys
if we get caught in here then help me oh
this is the dream up team up steven is
your father
all right familia let's go
i know a place i can access a security
terminal let you know what's coming
gaming marissa that was a little spooky
spot right use them if you get in a jam
oh shoot what's that get caught
don't get caught
did he not see me i was just
see that vent with the laser shielding
yeah yeah yeah how did you do that i've
worked with systems like this before now
focus looks like a good time to try out
those remote mines
what's going on with the cameras more
power outages
the remote mine can be used to shock a
group of enemies or overload highlighted
fuse boxes for bonus damage
okay
okay
what happens now
why am i yelling
what do i do oh oh oh oh
oh
i oh the signal
it's coming from somewhere deep on the
ground do that again lowest point in the
building is at the bottom of the reactor
silo then that's where i'm headed
come on boys get in there
wow
i want these everywhere i go
can you imagine how stealthy i'd be
wow
should we keep going with it right
i mean why not
but there's only one guy i can still use
it it doesn't matter
let's just
go over there bro
no no go to that thing go touch it let's
see what it is
would you go close to something if
see if i was a bad guy
and something started lighting up like
that i'd be like um that's us i don't
think i want to i don't want to be a
part
of that one leads to a land
reaction i see i see it i see a form
reactor that's what these schematics say
yeah
let's go
hey they should have mined their
business
the heat of phantom
we're trying to make more yes mason
didn't leave behind any note and
well i had heard that so silly new form
survived the uh incident on the bridge
now if we had access to that
don't you think that if i had it
i would give it to you does that guy
have bleach tips i just want to make is
that coming back that without that
canister it would be impossible to
that's big bad guy lighting big big big
big bad guy lighting
quaker's on a deadline
okay he's stressed he's on a deadline
you're looking for
tinkerers
oh
well
you're close to the reactor prototype
need to take these guys out
okay i got this i don't like being this
close to the reactor fuse boxes come on
let's do
wait for it
come on why didn't the other guy go in
there
come on everyone gather around
okay
where's that next one
hey what's over there
third guy go on
get
nah all right
okay can i where can i
okay no no oh man i almost just ran into
battle guys i almost just goofed
everyone that predicted that i might i
might goof i almost goofed
i almost goofed huge okay
guys guys guys guys come over here
i want to show you something
go over there both you guys come on put
yours
wait did you miss it
ah now
i got this guys i got this
am i out okay well we can't let
spiderman lead
what do i do now they're over
i put the
guys
now i gotta wait for them to ring around
the rosie like
all right
well maybe if i just i just let it
whoa what was that guys did you see that
over there
and that's suspicious
am i still out yeah i'm still out okay
well
maybe i can get this dude i should just
i could just go in how about a fight
how about if i do this the me way
oh that guy did not even see that
oh shoot just kidding
oh my gosh
he just he just blinked me it's all
right i got him he's good he's gonna
take a nap now
is there any more bad guys i just i'm
gonna get back up here
thanks
just on the other side of that
use that terminal to open it up okay i
got this i'll go back down that was
i'm still learning how to use those
things wait a second
there's more labs around the city oh
he's hacking the mainframe with a new
form reactor in each one
new form made rick sick
i need to shut these down
oh
[Music]
focus
this just made me realize i have
upgrades that i can spin wait oh my god
what's happening
oh my gosh
reactors below powers this whole
facility
bones all the way at the bottom
it looks like i need to figure out a way
past that fan guys no those guys too
remember what i said
don't get caught don't get caught this
looks like a very
a risky situation i'm not gonna lie
i'm starting to feel like i'm not very
qualified for whatever is about to go
down
okay
can i can i put can we do one of these
huh
what can we what can we do here
this is um all right
let's see
how about we hmm
i'm just gonna scoot this way
everyone
you know who i believe in
me
and i believe
that i can be stealthy
i really push myself to the limits am i
still out of these things when do
they okay
listen
oh no
i jumped
i'm enterprise i'm into press squad i
press circle
guys remember when i did that speech
about me being really stealthy and that
i believed in me
i still do i still do but that was that
was a test
i bet you didn't see that coming yeah i
didn't see that coming because i'm a
sneaky sneak
what's up didn't see that coming
didn't everyone else saw that mistake
coming though when i
did the wrong thing
it's cool
let's get this guy up here stealth icon
here
you know it's all part of the routine
actually
um if you didn't know
it it's uh
i kind of was just
i wanted to see if you guys were paying
attention and now that i know you are um
great job proud of everyone we're here
oh so cool
i'm so peaceful such a sucker for a
really good slow-mo shot i just i really
love it okay i think everything is
everyone's pretty much
taken down up here
just calling to make sure you're not
hurt or okay you know
thanks well the betty badge got my uncle
here taken care of up
here yeah the subway worker guy don't
speak about my uncle that way
wait
the prowler
the thief who runs around in purple
thief we're not partnering it's
i'll fill you in later
um
okay
guys
time for stealth round two
i got this everyone this majority of the
gameplay is just going to be me
working on myself
oh it's a danger i wasn't supposed to do
that
reading is hard sometimes i'm not going
to lie okay well guys i just
i messed up you know what it's not my
style anyways let's move let's go
[Music]
oh my gosh there is a lot of them though
guys this is just i don't know how good
this is
gonna be um okay well let's uh
let's bring these guys in how about we
let's just uh
bring those guys in to help me out just
a little bit
confuse things up
oh this guy's back
those are done charging
that was the wrong direction
okay she's the girl's panicking i'm a
little bit low on health i'm gonna
let my homies uh help me out for a
second i'm gonna dodge this guy
and go underneath them we're gonna just
play a little game right now
hang on i need to sort this out i'm a
mess i'm panicking
there we go i'm healed i'm good i'm good
everyone
no one needs to yell right now i got
this under control
and by no one i'm talking to myself
all right that guy's just gonna take a
nap
who else wants to take a nap
huh you do
all right just hang out there
literally oh this guy we're meeting in
the middle
what's up bro
can you imagine being so ready to like
throw some punches down and then you
just get
you just this happens to you trying to
shut down cameras and alarms this guy
was probably like break the wise
practicing
stuff his muay thai
all of his defense like he's got to
disable that he's been doing his
push-ups every day and he's like i can't
wait i can't wait till i see spider-man
i'm gonna i'm gonna punch him good
and then and then he was running at me
full speed he thought maybe we were
gonna is it gonna be a warm embrace and
and a good battle but nah
that did not happen okay
let's see
okay
so just a little bit of an update we're
rocking the new advanced tech suit
it is
wow
just the way that the light hits it
does something for me i'm just saying
we're making our way through roxanne's
uh roxan's lab to uncover the truth
behind new form
um that's just like a little recap for
you we learned that miles uncle is the
prowler
wait is there a biker there oh no that's
the guy we're talking about
there's a lot happening right now so
we're getting down to the bottom of it
okay
spinning blades of death
got it
now it's time for a puzzle okay dang
i've got to keep them in place somehow
all right we've we've done this before
so
yes
for the wires
okay
oh man
i got this
button mashing
check
wow look me i'm an engineer
sorted
all right let's go in here let's uh
let's hack the mainframe
it's down there
i'm getting really focused i'm sorry i
uh
the battery needs a charge
oh it's the worst it's the worst when
you're at it don't explode
nice
okay
i need that power in my life like
yesterday here it is
everyone in chat what percentage is your
is your phone at right now dumps a
two-person job i'm at 56 percent
here i confirm it there step one a
little too low
any regret
destroying the thing you made
you've seen me lately right
let's make the world safer
all right a little bit of a backstory
here uncovered
secret footage ready
ready it's about to go down triggering
override in
three two
man
that wasn't me
industrial sabotage rick
really
oh my gosh it's like stop motion on the
screen
don't be so mean
whoa this is intense
this must be really hard for finn
oh my goodness
someone else is in there
find out
rick was trying to save people
and krieger killed them huh
i have to finish what they started
uncle aaron can you unlock the reactor
shooting from where you are
why you got your phone now let's leave
oh reactor killed my friend come on
uncle aaron needs to be shut down
permanently be good guys i need your
help
come on
uh uncle aaron
okay
stand back
stand back
wow
50 of my muscles are all made up of
those quick actions
oh no
i'm not looking good oh no can i heal
myself yeah there we go
oh come on
oh my gosh this is intense
run
no no no no no
oh
but at least the reactor's disabled
you're almost out oh my goodness
i really needed that phone
now what am i going to do
come on kid i can't get too bad he
didn't have like like recording i
thought oh this oh geez
this guy we're taking you into custody
i'd like to see you try
wait what i gotta do oh disarm an enemy
okay well that that did not um
okay
okay this is this was this was not even
me not being sneaky this is just an
unfortunate
series of things that it said that have
happened um okay it's cool
i got this guys we're good
let's make this let's go night night guy
and then uh um yeah let's get up here
let's anyone want to hang out
okay well
how about this
do one of these guys that's the night
night punch just kidding that's not what
it's called i just made that up don't
listen to me
sweet that was that worked out my favor
wow that guy is very upset at me
i wonder if he gets a bonus for taking
me in
probably
he's the guy who is he was his partner
was probably the dude who was doing the
push-ups remember i was telling you
about it he was like practicing all day
for this
come on i got this
someone give you a hand you're trapped
nah
let's let's just take care of this real
quick
take care of this guy too
don't mind me i'm just try harding for a
second
i i really just sent me into a complete
panic
show
that was super cool cloaking i don't
know what you guys do whenever i'm
playing a game
you're gonna notice this happening now
that i'm pointing it out and maybe i
shouldn't
but like i do this thing with my lips
where i'm like
it's almost oh my oh my gosh i was
explaining
my weird thing that i do i forgot that i
was actually kidding again
i threw that at the wrong person
oh man
oh my gosh i'm nervous i'm panicking
it's okay it's okay i got this
oh that team up
what that was incredible did you see
that
i'm screaming again i'm so sorry that
was really cool
oh my gosh that was so cool
it was an unk moment
he came through he helped me out i love
that for us
come on family team up
where's this dude
oh yeah i'm on that guy
what are we doing here
oh there they are
[Music]
where's this next guy at where's he at
there he is
maybe i can get him to come over here
[Music]
nice
they just keep coming
bro come over here oh my god i didn't
even see that one
guys guys guys i have a little explosion
for you over here
am i supposed to leave am i supposed to
get out of here
no i oh this is not looking good though
i mean like he's he's not wrong i i
don't
okay my finisher's ready oh man
am i really supposed to leave uncle
aaron
is that was that was i just fighting for
like no reason like i was really
supposed to get out of there
you need to make it i can't
don't trust anybody and don't take off
that mask
wait till roxanne finds a better target
i can't lay low
i still need to find finn
i really i feel like i could have took
him out
i was
i was just getting the hang of it so
much about this
i was so close it's not just that
i'm
protecting new york is my job
alex torres 138 says who's your favorite
marvel superhero
tell her you want to join the
underground
i just told me don't take off the mess
don't tell her you spiderman
go to her as a friend oh prowler unk
that's a good idea
no she's too smart for that
you'd be surprised
people get stupid when they care about
something oh people get stupid when they
care about someone you're being stupid
now oh
no way
i don't get stupid when i care about
people
my heart gets bigger
and so does my brain
my brother
instead he cut me out
if i kept my mouth shut maybe i'd still
have a family
oh you know what you have to do
all right well he is obviously a little
jaded
a little little angry
oh that suit looks great that suit looks
so good
oh man
complete coffin
no no
favorite superhero it's a toss-up i
really love spider-man i've read a lot
of the comics miles you know how many
followers you've gained since the app
followers let's go i actually uh cosplay
as a spider-gwen that uh the whole
spider-verse is kind of just like my
favorite thing
but if i have to choose a top superhero
it's a toss-up between
carol danvers and kamala khan
i just i really love miss marvel i feel
like she represents like all of us you
know she she got started doing like fan
fiction for the avengers and she became
a superhero so
i know something about kamala that that
i really enjoy
um here's my skill tree that i was
talking to you guys about i need i need
help figuring out
uh where where this should go
um combat skills or uh venom
skills what do you guys think
uh mariana please tell us your tips and
tricks to be so stealthy well you know
you just gotta go in and you gotta not
think really
er like
hints and tips will pop up on the screen
but i don't see him i just go in
i don't i don't even read
that's that's what i do
i'm a puzzle pro yeah bree
the new suit is dope dorian right
what about you guys who's your favorite
uh superhero
but also
tell me where do i where should i put
this upgrade combat
i am always punching things
i could i could put it here
train technique allows a second finisher
to be banked
reduces combo requirement for a second
oh that that sounds great
or
increase venom smash area of effect
ah this one venom stunned enemies take
50 more damage from basic attacks venom
sun enemies knock into other enemies and
we'll transfer their venom stun
i'm kind of liking this one
the
i love banking another finisher move i
just i'm such a i'm such a sucker for
those slo-mo shots
and what if i team up with
uncle aaron again
i mean
i want to be ready
i want to have that
i want to have that one banked and ready
to go you know what i mean what do you
guys think
should i just do it
should i
i'm nervous i i i'm not i can't make
this this decision without you guys
oh wait
camouflage skills
whoa
this just popped up
camouflage energy refills 20 faster
that would make me more stealthy
i'm kind of working against the grain
here though with this thing we all know
that
stealth
even with camouflage
it's not my strong point
but it would be good to kind of get this
started right
let's let's just let's go for it
let's do it
i got three
i got oh what does this do
attacking while camouflage costs less
okay i said camouflage weird
i'm gonna get this one
whole triangle to yank and throw
ink and throw
guns imbued with bioelectric power it
will explode upon impact
that seems great but i don't have any
venom stuff increases the range of venom
punch damage
all right
we're gonna do one of these
and then i'm gonna do this one
and then we're gonna call it a day
because i'm out of skill points
thank you for that i said no to ads
before but maybe we could reconsider
no three names right now
of course not
i'm just saying i can just play this
game all day
i do
let's take a look at the
the mod visors
i don't have enough activity tokens to
get them but
these are pretty cool
all right
let's do uh
how about we do
um a combat spider training
what do you guys think of that
where are those at again
right there
right
oh that's the traversal challenge
i think i've already done that one
spooky stuff a stealth challenge
know your audience you know
know your strengths
no you're not strengths
you know what i mean
so did you find finn's phone wait i want
to see what this guy's saying to me but
uh it melted after i absorbed energy
from a new form reactor
what
how are you not dead
how is he not dead
but then i release all the energy in
kind of a mini explosion whoa we can
transfer his energy
man i gotta start taking notes on all
your new powers
so what's the plan now uncle aaron
thinks i should tell finn i want to join
the underground
then i can take the new form so she
doesn't what do you guys think whatever
joining the underground good idea
yes no yeah
they kind of have cool outfits they
don't have any other leads you know what
we need don't say a pros and cons list a
pros and cons i mean that's this guy's
smart he knows a pros and cons list is
clutch well good luck call if you need
me
can do
all right
taking a look at this real quick
there we go there's the combat challenge
my bad i was not even looking in the
right
place ah let's test out some of those
new moves how about we do that
let's flip on out of here
oh i was almost about to
ride the train for a second
let's go buddy
so we have all those cool new moves that
we just got
hey friends
apparently
jameson heard that i'm
why is this
the minute i start like uh
just like going
web slinging through the city
it i feel like that could be like um
just like a meditation right
i it really just chills me out
all right here we go let's do a combat
training no promises
no promises here but i i i feel like
this
this can be a little bit of character
development for me
i think i'm about to level up
what's up
know the peter way to end a fist fight
don't use your fists
in this challenge
grab stuff spin it around and whack
enemies with it you can grab objects
enemy weapons even other enemies got it
every hit scores a point
throw things we're gonna throw stuff
gotcha gotcha
okay cool cool
i can do this come on
okay yeah yeah piece of cake
okay
all right this is the one that we're
that we just upgraded
all right
why is this going so much better than
when it does when i'm actually like
i need to get the the weapon thing down
pulling it
out of their hands i think that is
something i'm
that's something i definitely panic with
okay yeah
very satisfied there we go
oh i forgot this is timed i'm just
sitting here just having a great time
smashing bros
get this in
come on last one
big
account oh no that's it
you're the ultimate miles
hey yeah
well done spider squire guys i got a
good score
now that you've got your throwing down
try extending your wind up before
release good way to clear some space
next challenge thanks pete extended wind
up good idea press r3 to track down okay
i gotta do it
cough in
get her to let me in the underground hey
that wasn't too bad hey miles i'm not
gonna lie you okay that that
i did all right guys say that oh
uh i saw the news about your mom's rally
we're fine all right finn do you have
time to get coffee maybe
i'm gonna have to talk to finn guys i'm
gonna have to tell finn
near fisk tower
they don't do foam art but people don't
take pictures
but finn does worth it
do you think miles no spoilers
no spoilers but do you think miles would
actually like
tell fenn like hey i saw i i know that
it's you
like let's cut it out or you think i
just don't know if if miles was like too
great of a liar
i just i just don't know if he could he
could do that i i would have a tough
time especially if it was like one of my
friends i'd be like uh i don't know i
don't know about this one um
anyways guys thank you so much for
hanging out with me uh it's been so fun
uh this is marvel's spider-man miles
morales exclusively on playstation four
and five uh we checked out the new
advanced tech suit which is available
now
be sure to go into photo mode take some
pictures tag me at strawberry17 and at
marvel games i would love to see your
guys's cool photos there's so many like
cool sticker options we did not we
didn't even you didn't see the half of
it you could really get crazy with all
of the uh the filters and you know
editing um but
i hope you enjoyed my playthrough i'm
megan camarena this is marvel
your universe thanks for hanging out
guys
you